le 4 octobre à 7h du matin l'ouragan
mathiot classé en ouragan de catégorie 4
frappe haïti avec des vents de 230
km/heure malgré l'anticipation
les pertes humaines et matérielles sur
l'île furent catastrophiques
[Musique]
plus d'un millier de personnes
trouvèrent la mort lors du passage de
l'ouragan mathiot et des centaines de
milliers de foyers sur détruit par cette
tempête
elle laissa plus d'un million de
personnes tributaires de l'aide
humanitaire et des dégâts estimés à
presque 2 milliards de dollars
[Musique]
après le saccage d'haïti cuba
le 4 octobre à 20h matthew fera pas de
plein fouet hao cours avec des vents de
220 km heure
[Musique]
l'ondé de tempête causé des dommages
considérables dans la province de
guantanamo la splendide vieille ville
espagnole de baracoa fut en particulier
terriblement abîmée
cependant grâce à l'efficacité de la
protection civile cubaine
aucune perte ne fut à déplorer
[Musique]
l'interaction avec la terre sur cuba
fille faiblir l'ouragan en catégorie 3
bien que matthew est finalement retrouvé
une intensité de catégorie 4 en quittant
cuba pour les bahamas le 5 octobre
matthew alors qualifié en catégorie 4
fera pas les côtes pour la troisième
fois
cette fois sur l'île de guam bab
les préparatifs commencèrent alors
véritablement dans le sud des états unis
à la proche de matthew plusieurs régions
déclarèrent l'état d'urgence sur les
régions côtières et on ordonne à des
évacuations massives
[Musique]
au cours des trente six heures suivantes
la tempête longeait la côte sud est des
états unis s'atténuant progressivement
tout en restant au large avant de
s'abattre une quatrième et dernière fois
sur les côtes de caroline du sud
au matin du 8 octobre le cyclone avait
alors la puissance d'un ouragan de
catégorie les dégâts furent
principalement limités aux côtes de
floride et de géorgie aux états unis
l'ouragan causa la mort de 47 personnes
[Musique]
le 9 octobre mathieu repris la direction
du large et un cheval sa transformation
en cyclone extra tropicales
avec des dégâts estimés à plus de 8
milliards de dollars matthew fut
l'ouragan atlantique le plus coûteux de
puissantes 10 en 2012
mais tous les pays ne sont pas exposés
de la même manière je là où il est
facile de souscrire des polices
d'assurance dans les pays les plus
riches
les gens ont tendance à construire des
immeubles solide de meilleur bâtiment
ils ont tendance à suivre les règles et
normes de construction et si vous
travaillez dans des pays en voie de
développement
on t'en vas plus de risques les choses
ne sont pas construites aussi solidement
il y a beaucoup de bâtiments dans les
zones inondables par exemple il existe
moins de protection pour les populations
et ce sont donc des défis très
différents à relever si vous êtes à
bisser des modèles de risque pour les
pays riches ou si vous réfléchissez aux
risques pour les pays pauvres du
tiers-monde mon poids de développement
dans lesquels les conséquences des
cataclysmes peuvent être cruciales pour
la vie des gens
[Musique]
une certitude demeure les catastrophes
naturelles frappe plus les pauvres que
les riches
[Musique]
si nous pouvons au moins attribué
quelques-uns de ces cataclysmes créée
par notre planète vivante au fait
qu'elle se réchauffe il reste plus
urgent que jamais d'instaurer des
politiques climatiques pour protéger les
plus vulnérables de ce monde
[Musique]
l'homme